aujourd'hui on va parler du nouveau
service de whatsapp whatsapp statut et
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à dire dessus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on parle de watsa works a
fait sortir une toute nouvelle mise à
jour avec une fonctionnalité toute
nouvelle qui s'appelle statut qu'est ce
que ce statut statut si tout simplement
la copie conforme
à quelque chose près de snapshot une
mise à jour vous pouvez retrouver les
souris os android est aussi windows
phone en gros vous publiez un statut
sont une photo une vidéo ou un gif et
elle est accessible pendant 24 heures à
vos contacts ça je pense que tu connais
tu l'as déjà vu tu l'as déjà entendu
c'est tout simplement cela chat
d'ailleurs normalement tu dois connaître
aussi parce que c'est nachat c'est aussi
instagram et maintenant c'est sûr
whatsapp et qu'est ce que c'est le point
commun entre ça ça et ça facebook
facebook a voulu racheter snap chatte
snapshot a refusé et quelques années
facebook
ils ont sorti les stories directement
sur instagram l'année dernière et
maintenant les statuts sur what's app
sur snapshot l'audience est relativement
jeune il ya les sharks de plus en plus à
facebook le public plus jeunes
délaissent facebook pour aller sur snap
c'est plus sympa ça fait beaucoup et il
ya un très très grand succès facebook a
essayé de réagir pour plusieurs raisons
et pour capter notamment cette audience
jeune ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
facebook si tu veux c'est un peu plus le
réseau social des gens un peu plus
mature ans il ya tout le monde
toutes tranches d'âge c'est vrai qu'en
règle générale le public qui est plus
jeune par source n'a pas peut-être déjà
entendu parler un petit peu ya quelques
temps de whatsapp qui voulaient sortir
effectivement cette version de statut
parce qu'au mois de novembre dernier
ils ont proposé à les utilisateurs de
tester cette nouvelle version
donc elles étaient restreintes à très
très très peu de personnes voilà
maintenant aujourd'hui elle est sortie
au grand public et tout le monde peut la
voir
whatsapp il faut quand même savoir que
c'est 1,2
milliard d'utilisateurs par mois 60
milliards de messages par jour dont 3 3
milliards de photos 760 millions de
vidéos et 80 millions de juifs ça tous
les jours
c'est incroyable instagram stories qui a
été lancé l'année dernière a maintenant
plus de 150 millions d'utilisateurs par
jour alors forcément tout ça ça réduit
les parts de marché de snapshot et salue
nuit énormément je vais te montrer et
expliquer comment fonctionne cette
nouvelle application tu vas voir que tu
vas vraiment reconnaître certaines
choses que tu as vu là dedans voire
quasiment tous je te demande comment ça
marche directement sur mon appui on nous
voit de sap
on nous voit de sable jusque là rien de
bien compliqué et tu vas sur ce statut
donc tu as mon statut en eau directement
et on sue tu as les dernières mises à
jour donc pour l'instant moi aucun de
mes amis il utilise fugue est une toute
nouvelle fonctionnalité
donc j'ai uniquement le statut de
whatsapp qu'on a regardé ce que ça donne
tu regardes up donc ça te met bien vu
dans les nouveaux horaires en haut tu
vois la barre qui défilent ensuite
s'enchaînent vous pouvez désormais
modifier partager vos photos vidéos le
gif
s'enchaînent ensuite les mises à jours
disparaissent après 24 heures c'est
marrant ça me rappelle quelque chose
partagez les événements de vos journées
avec vos contacts
tu vois ça montre même des lunettes
parce qu'à penser à lunel snap château
sinon contrôler qui peut voir vos mises
à jour dans les paramètres de
confidentialité tout ça je le montrais
tu vas voir c'est extrêmement simple
à vous de jouer essayer de partager vos
statuts allez on y va
donc je te montre tu cliques en haut à
droite pour prendre une photo
ça c'est ma tronche si en train de
filmer hop on met la photo par là tu
vois là tu as une belle photo une belle
tête de vainqueur
maintenant tu vas cliquer par exemple
sur le petit smiley tu choisis le
smiling tu veux allez hop on va le faire
le veut le faire un peu lolilol hop un
petit smiley marrant c'est vrai qu'on
rigole tu peux rajouter deux esprits qui
peut même faire les mêmes astuces qui
assure slap shade c'est à dire prendre
pour smiley du louvre à fond tu te
décale sans le côté up et tu peux comme
ça m un petit filtre sur ta photo tu
vois ça c'est une astuce nachat mais qui
peut aussi marcher pour ça tout
simplement avec la transparence de ton
l'émoticône alors tu mets ça ensuite tu
va rajouter du texte en appuyant sur le
thé le tu es tu vas te mettre un gros on
s'en fout un bouc ou par exemple tu vois
non pas coquille coucou parfait tu peux
changer la couleur sur le côté
exactement comme sorte nachat tu vois
c'est la même chose tu le mets en gros
tu le fait pivoter tu le mets comme tu
veux bon ça fait jeune sur jeune mais ça
marche aussi tu peux ajouter une petite
légende en dessous et l'eau qui sera la
légende de ta photo tu l'envoies pas
tout de suite tu peux la faire pivoter
si tu le souhaites tu peux la croupe es
tu là mais comme tu veux tu la coupe tu
leur taille directement comme tu
souhaites up donc la tat photo tu peux
revenir à l'origine s'est appuyé sur la
petite flèche bac mais il ya aucun
intérêt et ensuite tu en vois ça public
directement ton nouveau statut whatsapp
pour la vidéo c'est pareil tu te mets
dessus tu laisses appuyé tu monte vers
le haut tu joues tu vas vers le bas tu
des zooms donc bon tu peux tu éclaté un
peu ça fait même gerber vous demanderont
si tu veux donc voila tu as fait ta
vidéo tu peux la mettre en lecture pour
voir en ôter une barre de navigation qui
permet de modifier ta vidéo up est ce
que tu veux bien que lire tu peux la
mettre soit en vidéo soit en gif en
gissac la vie tu vois donc tu fais un
montage après pour avoir le givre que tu
veux hop comme tu veux qu'il soit monté
si moi par exemple je veux la fin qui
fait que zoom et je mets là et ça me
fait un juif tu vois bon c'est ça donne
envie de gerber hop tu envoies et ça
envoie mongis directement c'est
extrêmement simple
donc tu vois tu vas faire ton statut ça
c'était moi hier soir en train de manger
de risotto que je vais cuisiner
ensuite le petit bug pour la vidéo
d'avant ensuite bon bah j'avais fait un
test un appareil à notre test tu peux
colorisées faire des dessins directement
bout de ton doit aussi ça c'est l'egypte
qui sont proposés chez que le montrer
dans quelques instants
ensuite la photo qu'on vient de faire
tout de suite et puis ensuite le dernier
chiffre que j'ai fait à nîmes et voilà
donc voila un petit peu le principe est
ensuite ce qui est bien c'est que tu
vois tout en bas le nombre de personnes
qui l'ont regardé tu vois 0 vue pour
celle là forcément moi j'ai aucun de mes
amis qui pour l'instant utilisent cette
application
quand tu fais tes vidéos quand a décidé
de faire ta vidéo
tu peux cliquer en bas tout en bas à
droite c'est pour faire soit une photo
ou une vidéo de phase soit pas si sûr
notre caméra est tout en bas à gauche tu
vas avoir accès directement à toutes tes
photos mais sitôt culture gif tout en
bas à gauche
hop qu'est ce que tu as tu as tous les
juifs qui sont proposés directement et
après il ya une confidentialité tu peux
choisir que ce soit tout le monde qui va
directement ce que tu publies soit un
certain nombre de personnes les habitats
désigné soit carrément exclure des
jeunes en groupe pour autre petit détail
directement écho de sap quand par
exemple tu es en train de publier une
photo
tu vois attaque je fais une photo je
veux tapé mon texte je marque qooq où tu
vois le grand coucou tu change la
couleur comme si elle disait mais tu
peux aussi changer la police tu te mets
dessus tu te mets directement sur la
sélection de la couleur et tu vas sur la
gauche et tu as différents styles
d'écriture
donc tu vas voir du souligné tu vas voir
des choses un petit peu plus un peu
moins conventionnelles un petit peu
moins sûrs de l'arial voilà donc à
différentes choses et tu te fais du coup
comme tu veux tu vois ça marche comme ça
tu vois le truc c'est extrêmement simple
alors au final est-ce que c'est
intéressant d'utiliser les statuts ou
whatsapp il ya un vrai gros point
positif qui est très intéressant c'est
pas forcément intéressant pour tout le
monde et puis toujours ne pas forcément
mettre le focus là dessus mais ce qui
est vraiment bien c'est la technologie
de chiffrement c'est à dire que whatsapp
garantit un chiffrement de a à z donc
une vraie sécurité au niveau des données
et au niveau des infos que tu revois en
règle générale seront envoyées par
snapshot whatsapp comme ça aussi ou
alors tout simplement
instagram stories en règle générale pas
trop confidentielle mais bon tu peux
vouloir qu'on ne voit pas la photo de
ton chaque condo patate est alors après
je sais pas ce que tu racontes et que tu
envoies des nues et où quelqu'un tu veux
un petit peu le cacher toujours est il
que il y aura t'il vraiment que la
formation va être complètement sécurisé
et ça c'est vraiment le gros point
positif est qu'on peut accorder
effectivement à what's app
alors au final c'est quoi le but de
toute application parce qu'il ya
plusieurs luttes en réalité tout doute
bien que si la société qui appartient au
final à mark zuckerberg n'est pas
facebook a décidé de mettre ses statuts
sur votre sapin ya bien plusieurs buts
alors il ya plusieurs on va les regarder
ensemble
le tout premier but c'est clair que
c'est de dégommer snapshot out snapshot
on prend les par marché vous n'avez pas
voulu être achetés à trois ans c'est pas
grave maintenant tant pis vous avez
jamais ce qu'ils font en place et je
récupère le business
ça c'est tout premier point le deuxième
c'est d'ouvrir de nouveaux horizons
publicitaire havas a forcément whatsapp
avec ses fonctionnalités là vont pouvoir
attirer de nouveaux annonceurs et ça va
être aussi tout bénef pour eux savard a
mis des dollars troisième point attirer
de nouveaux utilisateurs
ça risque de rage et l'irascible les
gens vont bien sûr votre sac pour
communiqué envoyé des photos envoyer des
messages comme ils le font déjà
par contre avec cette fonctionnalité là
ça risque d'attirer de nouveaux
utilisateurs
quatrième point fidéliser l'audience
actuelle et la gardien encore plus
longtemps dans l'application
elle irait regarder directement ce qu'on
appelle les stories mais elle est en
réalité les statuts elle passera plus de
temps
connecter à l'application et après ça
rejoint 2.2 comme elles restent
connectés plus longtemps on peut lui
proposer plus de cubes ont fait plus
d'argent et au final on finit par des
comètes un chat et puis cinquième fois
c'est tout simplement de conquérir des
territoires
la housse lapchak n'est pas aujourd'hui
certains pays d'europe de l'est
certaines régions d'amérique du sud
et puis en règle générale tous les pays
en développement les pays ou encore
snapshot n'est pas hyper fort et où il
ya encore du business à faire avant que
si whatsapp arrive à s'imposer avant
tout quand on connaît la force de votre
sapin haut niveau de l'envoi de messages
au niveau des vidéos au niveau du texte
on se doute bien que ils n'auront pas du
mal à percer là où snap chaque n'est pas
présent et si tu es habitué dès le
départ à utiliser une application il ya
très peu de chances que tu switch sur
l'autre c'est te propose pas quelque
chose de vraiment différent
surtout que quelle va être la vraie
différence de snapshot par rapport à
whatsapp baisse avec les informations
tout ce qui va être un petit peu plus
dit organisée on va avoir du contenu de
médias des choses comme ça et du contenu
qu'il va vraiment garder les
utilisateurs
sauf que ça watsa ne propose pas et dans
les pays en développement ces services
là ils vont pas être vraiment très
intéressant donc on se doute bien que si
on va de sa part il a capté des gens
avant qu'il ait un chat
ils risquent de les garder plus souvent
est une fois de plus ça va nuire et qui
a snapshot et après et après qu'est ce
qu'on peut imaginer
parce qu'après l'avoir mis directement
sur instagram après l'avoir mis sur
what's app pourquoi pas sur facebook
alors c'est pas forcément le but sans
facebook ont fait garder un peu plus il
ya une timeline qui est définie et on
garde les informations facebook campus
amie anna gorille pour leur proposer et
remettront je souhaite a déjà publié est
pour refaire vivre un petit peu le passé
donc ils ont aucun intérêt à voir des
publications éphémère sauf qu'en réalité
on a déjà vu qui avait déjà des choses
un petit peu plus éphémères qui pouvait
apparaître tu peux mettre une photo de
profil et
dire qu'elle ne va être en ligne puis
pendant quelques jours avec moi mais j
attends ligne tout le temps ça par
exemple c'est quelque chose qui existe
déjà sur facebook
donc on peut imaginer pourquoi pas que
ils prennent aussi un petit peu le pli
pour essayer d'attirer un public un peu
plus jeune
alors que facebook sort public là est un
petit peu en perte de vitesse et puis au
final avec la multiplication des offres
snapshot va être noyé dans la masse au
final qui doit faire le choix tu vas pas
utiliser le même service sur toutes les
applis instagram c'est génial moi
personnellement j'utilise énormément
donc le boulot qui fait sur instagram le
cas sur ce match at tu fais des doublons
et leur faire carrément sur what's app
bon il ya un moment tu va choisir et au
final sur la multiplication des offres
le grand gagnant c'est qui c'est le
groupe de mark zuckerberg est le grand
perdant c'est qui cessna chat donc au
final il va falloir que snapshot
réagissent très vite en proposant de
nouvelles fonctionnalités pour réussir à
garder les gens proposer de nouveaux
services et innover sans innovation j'ai
bien peur que ce match at continue à
faire une grande dégringolade et
beaucoup de mal à remonter la pente
il faut savoir que depuis que instagram
stories est sorti aux états unis ils ont
déjà fait perdre 40% son audience a
snapshot 40%
c'est presque la moitié c'est monstrueux
donc là on attend un petit peu la
réaction de snapshot et on attend aussi
la prochaine offensive du groupe de mark
zuckerberg dans un petit peu ce qu'ils
vont proposer sans quoi ils vont se
positionner
de toute façon snapshot est obligé de
réagir ils vont être obligés d'innover
j'ai proposé une nouvelle chose s'il
veut sortir un peu la tête de l'eau dis
moi ce que t'en penses tu es sur ce
match at tu l'est pas c'était sur ce
match at voilà mon snow code vienne me
rejoindre
c'était sur instagram monsieur
underscore boureux tu viens tu me
rejoins aussi facebook il ya la page
monsieur greva là on reste connectés
toi par contre dis-moi que tu utilises
ticehurst nachat oui ou non
instagram stories oui ou non est ce que
tu penses utiliser à l'avenir les
statuts whatsapp et à télécharger la
nouvelle mise à jour de l'application
voilà donc dix mois peu tout ça tu le
mets en commentaire on ouvre une
discussion et tu me dis ce que tu en
penses n'hésite pas à regarder cette
vidéo là qui est très sympa tu ta bonne
directement
merci beaucoup et je te dis à très
bientôt